- Which Disney villain are you?
Because let's face it,
- [Congregated] princesses are boring.
- Ooh.
(record scratching)
- Wooh.
(sign squeaking)
(electronic music)
- Hey guys, we are at BuzzFeed.
We are the cast of Descendants 2.
I am Dove Cameron.
- I am China Anne McClain.
- And I am Sofia Carson.
- And we're going to take the
Which Disney Villain Are You Quiz.
And I just wanna point out that this
is a really awesome visual--
- Graphic.
- Of our epic mothers.
- [China] Oh yeah.
- Take a look at that,
because how epic are they?
Okay guys, question number one,
what's your greatest quality?
I'm gonna go with
- [China] Sinister.
- Being ambitious.
- Yeah, I would say being sinister?
- I was about to say that too, actually.
- Go with sinister, you be you, boo-boo.
- I wanna go with sinister,
that's right.
- [China] Do you, boo.
- What is your ideal lair?
- [China] Oh!
A castle on top of a mountain.
Done.
- I'm gonna go with
a castle deep in the woods.
- Out in the wild, yes.
How would you describe your style?
- [Sofia] These are really good options.
- [Dove] These are a lot of good ones.
- I'm kind of between elegant,
but powerful and beautiful and regal.
- Mysterious.
- I would go with, are
you going with mysterious?
- Yes.
- I'm gonna go with, if I was a villain,
I'd like to be beautiful and
regal, like the evil queen.
- Elegant but powerful.
- [Sofia] How do you prefer your sidekick?
Sidekicks are very important, kids.
Usually, insane ones are the best ones.
- I don't like sidekicks.
- Wisecracking, Imma need that all day.
- Wisecracking?
But what if you're trying to be maniacal
and he keeps telling jokes,
and you're just like,
you're killing my vibe.
- Listen, it would be like--
- But that makes for good comedy,
that makes for a good movie.
- But this isn't a television show.
- Yeah, you need a--
- Though, like in real life?
- Well, well?
- It could be.
- Well, see,
but you know me, like don't ever get,
I'm always wisecracking.
I'm so annoying.
I'm your little insane sidekick.
- (laughs) Insane wisecracking annoying.
- That's me (laughing).
Hey, you can't say it, only I can say it.
- I'm just kidding, not.
- All three of the--
- I would say wisecracking.
- I'm going to go with--
- Or insane.
- I don't--
- I'm gonna go with insane
- A cunning sidekick would be helpful.
- [Sofia] What is the best
motivation to be evil?
So many.
- I don't, I could never
access anything for revenge.
- I'm gonna say to obtain power.
- Yeah, I don't care enough.
'Cause jealousy is just insecurity.
- But that's motivation.
- As in spite.
- I don't do well with people
doin' me wrong, though.
I might go with for revenge.
(China laughs)
- Okay, China.
- Why is this so funny?
This is like the funny--
- Sorry (laughs).
- Her commentary is killing me.
- Just go pick it and move on.
- I'm gonna go with out of pride.
- I'm gonna go with to obtain power.
- [Sofia] What is the best
accessory a villain can have?
- [Dove] I feel like I'm in the middle
of two, like, genuine villains.
- You are (scoffs).
- A staff, sorry guys.
- Yeah, Maleficent has a staff.
- Best accessory?
- Maleficent has a staff.
- I'm gonna go with a cauldron,
'cause I can poison apples in a cauldron.
- Yeah, none for me
because how am I gonna--
- And a wand.
- She works on her own.
- Have a cauldron, and be like,
try to be evil walkin'
around with a cauldron.
Okay, which of these powers is the best?
The ability of metamorphosis,
oh, that's cool.
- I read that as menopause.
(laughter)
- You, you, you.
- You get menopause, you get
menopause, you get menopause,
everybody gets menopause!
That was good, though.
- You guys, focus, God.
- Okay, I'm sorry.
- Being able to use
magic spells, you guys.
You can have--
anything you can do with a spell.
- I'm gonna go with the spell, as well.
- [Sofia] What're your power colors?
- Black and gray, black and gray.
- Red's a good color on me,
I'm gonna go with black and red.
What is your weapon of choice?
A henchman?
- That's good.
- I'll get a henchman.
- I'm gonna go with a henchman,
'cause I've got no need
to get my hands dirty.
- Magic, of course.
Imma go with magic, of course.
- Weapon of choice--
transformation, oh.
Because think about it, if you're like,
have powers of mystique.
- Transformation is good.
I'm going transformation.
- Yeah.
- Or you could also just want to look
like Angelina Jolie one day.
You're like, "I wish I look like,"
and then you do.
- Yeah, so you know what,
I'm going with that on both accounts.
Which of these do you hate the most?
True love (laughs).
- [Sofia] Hate it.
- [China] Hate it.
Beauty.
- Hate it.
- Oh, family.
- Oh, no.
- Hate it.
- (laughs) Not being included,
or those with more power.
- Yo, not being included.
- True love, obviously.
No, I'm just joking.
- Those with more power.
- I love people way too much.
If I'm on the outsides, I'm like.
Which is the best way to
get back at your enemies?
Embarrassing them, put a curse on them,
emotionally manipulating them,
(laughter)
emotionally manipulating
one of their loved ones,
(Sofia gasps)
or killing them.
(China laughs)
- Avada Kedavra.
- I wouldn't say killing them is too easy
of a end game.
- And also, if you kill them,
you can't get back at them easily.
Exactly.
- Put a curse on 'em.
- It's more torture--
I think it's more tortuous to manipulate
one of their loved ones.
- Emotionally manipulate one
of their loved ones, that's the worst.
That's dark, whoa.
- Get back at your enemies.
- That's some stuff that
like touched a part of me.
- [In Unison] Your biggest fear is:
Sword through the heart,
falling off a cliff,
having a boulder fall on you,
being entrapped in a small space,
or being struck by lightning.
- No.
- That was some really
uncomfortable cult stuff.
(China laughs)
- Sword through the heart--
- I could do that.
- Is gonna be a deal breaker for me.
- I think falling off a cliff would--
(Dove gasps)
- Being struck by lightning.
Oh c'mon, if both of you
guys got your people--
- This gon' be embarrassing if you don't.
- And I didn't get mine.
I got Scar guys.
(Sofia laughs)
I got Scar?
- Why do you keep getting the animals?
- I got Scar (laughs).
- I got the Evil Queen.
- I'm not even mad about this.
- I got Maleficent.
- No Scar is mean.
- I mean, they do say that Maleficent
is the most evil of them all, so.
- I am the daughter of the Evil Queen,
so it makes sense that I got
my mother, the Evil Queen.
- Hi mom.
- Hi mommy.
- Man, I'm happy.
(Sofia laughs)
(upbeat electronic music)
(record scratching)
(sign creaking)